et aujourd'hui c'est un peu une manière
de dire en tant que le respect qui nous
est venue soit montré la retraite est
complètement caractéristiques puisque ça
concerne tout le monde et vous êtes
fassis une attaque générale 3 border où
on a beaucoup de colère qui s'est
accumulée ces dernières années avec
notamment mais bon voilà beaucoup de
manque de personnel dans les hôpitaux
une grande manifestation à lille 14
voilà des salaires qui sont extrèmement
bas
aussi ai je pense que c'est un peu le
ras-le-bol général qui fait qu'on est
nombreux à s est déplacé là en fait à
l'hôpital de l'hôpital pour dire on est
notre colère quoi pour pouvoir garder le
garder nos acquis sociaux pour regarder
tout ça tout un système qui qui eux
le tout le moment nous envie je pense
que le fait que ce qu'on soit l'unique
on
confiante et ernst
c'est ont commencé à arriver à gagner la
partie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au but
[Musique]
autre
en
[Musique]
m
allez mon
[Musique]
c'est la liberté
oh
oui
[Musique]
oh
pour
[Musique]
bon
et
non
aujourd'hui pour vous le fera sans plan
convergences entre guillemets elle
concerne que les retraites elle et elle
est bien plus large que ça prend trois
points qu'on ait pendant du témoin
qu'ont annoncé les visions des choses
absolument incroyable pour les
professeurs qui n'arrive jamais encore
moins pour partager avec tous les autres
personnes ici c'est que peut pas
envisager de changement climatique sans
poser la question profondément de la
démocratie et de la remise en question
profonde aussi le modèle économique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui
comme jack